pierre laurin bonjour bonjour alors
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur sur rt france on entendu anthony
blinken appelé vladimir poutine à
choisir la voie pacifique 1 pour sortir
de la crise autour de l'ukraine est en
même temps les états unis engagent des
moyens financiers pour la sécurité de
l'ukraine comment décrypter cette
posture américaine
je crois que il y à un élément de
cynisme de la part des des américains
dans la mesure où
il y à des négociations qui sont
engagées entre la russie et les etats
unis il y avait également des
négociations entre l'otan et la russie
avaient qu'entre eux et c'est eux et la
russie c'est à dire que tous les
éléments sont en place pour essayer de
trouver des solutions à la sécurité à
l'est de l'orne en particulier bien
entendu en ukraine et dans le même temps
les états unis
manifeste très
lourdement leurs préoccupations sur
d'éventuelles
possibilités d'attac de la russie contre
l'ukraine alors que la situation sur le
terrain n'évolue pas réellement du côté
russe il ya des déplacements de trous
mais rien ne les interdit en revanche
sur la ligne de front du donbass il n'y
a pas de déplacement de troupes du côté
de ceux qu'on appelle les séparatistes
qui sont en fait des autonomistes en
revanche il y à des mouvements de
troupes de l'autre côté du côté
ukrainien
donc il y à la une comment dirais-je eu
une certaine incompréhension de la
position américaine
maintenant ce qui est clair c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
blinken est à kiev pour rencontrer
volodymyr zelensky et lui rapporter
parce que c'est ça l'important lui
rapporter ce qui a été décidé ou non
décider lors des rencontres entre les
états unis en russie la semaine dernière
je crois que c'est traditionnel pour la
diplomatie d'un pays d'aller informer
ceux qui sont concernés dans le même
temps
aujourd'hui
et publié cette nouvelle d'une aide de
200 millions de dollars supplémentaires
rappelons qu'en 2021 l'aide avait été de
450 millions de dollars d'ailleurs près
d'un demi milliard
et cette aide est annoncée aujourd'hui
alors qu'elle ait été décidée le mois
dernier donc là il y a une volonté
manifeste des américains de faire
coïncider
cette annonce avec la visite de blink de
manière à dramatiser la situation et
surtout à bien montrer que les
etats-unis se tiennent derrière
l'ukraine et la soutiennent maintenant
le problème de ce soutien c'est jusqu'où
peut-il aller
les ukrainiens du moins certains
ukrainiens sont persuadés que s'il y
avait un affrontement armé dans le
donbass les américains interviendrait
militairement ce que le président joe
biden a démenti il y a quelques semaines
et c'est cela aujourd'hui qui retient à
mon avis les ukrainiens d'essayer
d'aller plus loin dans une éventuelle
reconquête des régions
autonomistes du dôme ans et côté rue du
coup c'est là la volonté de la voie
diplomatique inquiets qui est privilégie
aujourd'hui
du côté russe a toujours été la voie
diplomatique les russes veulent depuis
le départ l'application des accords de
minsk les ukrainiens
joue sur les termes des accords en
prétendant que
le changement de la constitution
ukrainienne qui est prévu par les
accords ne pourra intervenir que lorsque
la situation sur le terrain serait réglé
et que la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la russie seraient surtout
son tracé
tenus par des troupes ukrainienne mais
ce n'était pas ça qui avait été négociée
avec
le gouvernement ukrainien de l'époque de
monsieur prochaine qu à minsk en février
1981 pardon 2015 je crois que
tant que la situation
ne sera pas réglée sur les accords de
minsk sur la volonté de signer ou pas
des accords de minsk il n'y aura pas de
progrès en revanche il est très clair
aujourd'hui que
tant que les négociations se
poursuivront entre les etats unis l'otan
et la russie il est peu probable que la
russie engagent des actions militaires
sauf évidemment en cas de d'attac de
l'armée ukrainienne contre le dôme bas
cela on ne sait pas ce qui pourrait
arriver mais là c'est aux américains de
prévenir leurs alliés ce qui est en
train de faire certainement anthony
blinken auprès de du président zielinski
c'est aux américains de dire attention
ne vit n'est pas toutes les chances de
la paix essayons de progresser
sur la voie de la diplomatie et sur la
voie pacifique juge maintenant oui oui
juste en un mot en arrivons au terme du
temps qui nous est imparti anthony
blinken doit rencontrer au sergueï
lavrov à genève vendredi à quoi peut-on
s'attendre
eh bien on peut s'attendre à la
poursuite du dialogue c'est à dire là ce
qui est en enjeu c'est l'établissement
d'un calendrier de négociations pour
l'avenir il y a une robe contre il y en
aura d'autres quand bien c'est à
déterminer lille est longtemps a proposé
un calendrier et la russie s'est donné
le temps de réfléchir je crois que la
rencontre entre blinken lavrov portera
essentiellement sur cela et puis blinken
rapportera à saré lavrov les le
compte-rendu disons de l'entrevue qu'il
aura eu avec le président zelensky merci
beaucoup pierre laurin pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes journaliste écrivain
spécialiste de la russie